So now, we have an equation that can be implemented on the computer.
Let's start by simulating the following situation.
A wire is briefly heated by a candle so that some part of the wire is at the temperature of the flame
and the rest of the wire is at room temperature is times zero
We blow out the candle so that there's no more heating
and then we watch heat conduction in action.
How does this energy spread to the left and to the right.
The code comes with some pretty fine constants for your convenience.
It provides to erase one with the old temperatures at the beginning of the step
and one for the new temperatures at the end of the step.
And you have to compute the new temperature from the old temperatures
for the compartment number i
A note about the implementation in case you're wondering about this line here,
we're exchanging the roles of these two arrays temperatures new,
temperatures old after every step.
Once the new temperatures have been computed, they become the old temperatures for the next step,
which means that one of these arrays can be reused for the new, new temperatures if you will.
This saves us from using tons of arrays. We're just using these two arrays with different roles.